[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 21 mai si 100 startups
275 laboratoires de recherche publics et
privés des centres r&d deux grands
groupes
l'écosystème paris saclay regroupe de
nombreux acteurs de l'innovation
chaque année l'événement paris saclay
spring permet de prendre le pouls de ce
bassin unique en europe alors que ce
rendez-vous s'achève ce 21 mai nous
faisons le point avec jérémy hervé
directeur du développement économique et
de l'innovation au sein de cet
établissement public d'aménagement du 22
au 30 mai la croix rouge française
organise ses journées nationales et à
sartrouville l'unité locale se
mobilisent en organisant des journées de
collecte sur trois communes enfin côté
loisirs cette semaine un agenda qui se
remplit pour ce premier week-end de
déconfinement avec célia get on go nous
irons à thoiry et dampierre et nous
évoquerons la fête de la nature 2021
juste avant cela le gouvernement l'a
annoncé ce jeudi 20 mai
la vaccination contre le coc vide 19
sera ouverte dès le 31 mai à tous les
plus de 18 ans soit deux semaines avant
la date prévue au calendrier
autre information à saint quentin en
yvelines le vaccinodromes ouvre vendredi
21 mai de 20h à 23h la vaccination pour
tous les commerçants et salariés ainsi
que les agents territoriaux sans
condition milk réno prévu pour ces
professions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre le
paris saclay spring rendez vous de
l'innovation s'est tenue ce 20 et 21 mai
si 100 startups 275 laboratoires de
recherche publics et privés des centres
recherche et développement de grands
groupes
l'écosystème paris-saclay regroupe
beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs de
l'innovation pour en parler nous
accueillons en visioconférence avec nous
jérémy hervé bonsoir ou encore vous êtes
donc le directeur du développement
économique et de l'innovation au sein de
l'établissement public
ep à nous dirons au pea ensuite paris
saclay alors d'abord comment s'est
déroulé cet événement le paris saclay
spring sur ses 48 heures à écouter je
pense que le stade édition qui est donc
la troisième édition de paris saclay
spring s'est très bien déroulé on a eu
un beau succès près de 2000 participants
beaucoup de rendez vous d'affaires ont
pu être tenus et beaucoup de contacts
ont pu être établi entre les différents
participants soit dans le cadre de
rendez-vous en amont soit sur le salon
virtual là où on pouvait aussi interagir
avec les exposants et puis également sur
le plateau télé une belle réussite avec
neuf heures de direct des grandes
conférences et c'est une réussite aussi
en terme de deux performances sur ce
plateau télé puisqu'on avait pas moins
de 78 intervenant sur ces neuf heures de
live avec des grands temps forts donc
une belle réussite pour nous malgré des
conditions cette année a évidemment un
petit peu plus particulière que les
précédentes éditions vous l'évoquez en
effet écrit sanitaire oblige une partie
de paris saclay spring était en digital
comment ça s'est passé pour organiser ce
que vous aviez des craintes que cette
crise sanitaire empêche pas respring
paris saclay spring 2021 oui on avait
des craintes alors comme tous les
événements ils s'organisent un nom à
l'avance l'été dernier tous les voyants
étaient au vert mais comme on avait dû
annuler l'édition 2020 on voulait être
préparé au pire un donc on avait
envisagé le scénario du pire qui était
celui du confinement
et donc on avait préparé tous les outils
pour pour être distant ciel à la fois un
plateau télé pour remplacer toutes les
conférences toutes les conférences les
tables rondes qui se déroule normalement
en présentiel
on avait également un salon virtuel pour
faire face à l'absence de pouvoir se
retrouver
donc on avait tous les outils digitaux
on était prêts pour cette édition et
puis les intervenants sur le plateau
évidemment respecter tous les protocoles
en vigueur
voilà donc ça a pu se dérouler malgré
des conditions évidemment difficile et
pas forcément souhaitable
on l'imaginé bien alors party digital
ont bien d'en parler mais y avait aussi
une partie quand même entre guillemets
en présentiel
à l'occasion de cet événement les
entreprises du ce territoire qu'est
paris saclay à cheval entre l'essonne et
les yvelines
ouvrez quand même leurs portes pour
faire découvrir leur travail en la
matière via les circuits de l'innovation
une partie de cet événement c'était le
cas ce vendredi 21 mai de dans will
entreprises par dont bouygues
construction est son site challenger à
guyancourt
le groupe s'est associé et on voit le
reportage de grégory canal installé sur
ce site de 30 hectares depuis 1988
bouygues construction a profité du paris
saclay sprint pour dévoiler son siège et
ses activités au cours d'une matinée un
circuit de l'innovation en petits
groupes crise sanitaire oblige est
divisé en deux parties
les participants ont pu découvrir
notamment le travail du groupe pour
rendre les territoires plus connectés et
durable internet a reconnectés est un
territoire qui intègre des technologies
qui connectent l'ensemble des
infrastructures qui sont à sa
disposition des infrastructures de vidéo
protection des signalisations de feux
tricolores d'éclairage public
les bâtiments de la ville et tous et la
communique au sein d'un hyperviseur où
une centrale qui permet d optimiser la
gestion des saisons fera structure un
parcours qui s'est poursuivie au design
là d'une nouvelle salle présente sur le
site
l'objectif montrer ce que la technologie
peut apporter au monde de la
construction notamment grâce aux outils
de réalité virtuelle et augmentée
tout ceci nous permet soit
d'améliorer notre qualité sur les
chantiers d'assister les personnes sur
les chantiers pour implanter des
ouvrages pour travailler plus facilement
soit également en amont comment on peut
aider le client à se projeter sur le
bâtiment terminé alors qu'il n'est pas
encore construit et la vingtaine de
participants a pu tester ces
technologies ont vraiment ce qui se
passe au numéro niveau technologique et
on peut partager avec les autres
c'est vraiment bien immersif c'était
l'occasion pour moi de voir ce qui se
faisait autour de la smart cities et les
clients ce matin était intéressante
parce que voilà il ya un environnement
de démo on voit aussi des applications
concrètes proposées ce vendredi 21 mai
dans le cadre du paris saclay ce prime
ces circuits de l'innovation se sont
déroulés en tout dans 10 entreprises et
grands groupes du territoire
jérémy hervé vous êtes toujours en
visioconférence avec nous je le rappelle
directeur de l'innovation et du
développement économique au sein de le
paix à paris saclay alors on l'a vu dans
ce reportage est ce que pour vous aussi
c'est une réussite ces circuits de
l'innovation ses visites en entreprises
bah je crois que vos images le montrent
en avait proposé un planning de plus de
10 appuie l'innovation donc on a ouvert
les portes de 10 centres de r&d que ce
soit public ou privé parce qu'il y avait
aussi des laboratoires notamment les
laboratoires de l'observatoire de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
donc beaucoup avaient accepté de jouer
le jeu des portes ouvertes et je crois
que c'est une occasion rare ici ou de
pouvoir visiter ce genre de sites
voilà c'était pour nous la possibilité
de garder au moins cette partie là en
présentiel le lien avec le territoire
qui est essentiel et l'année prochaine
j'espère qu'on peut tous se retrouver et
pas uniquement sur les siècles
l'innovation donc deux jours des changes
48 heures qui ont aussi vu la
constitution d'un réseau d'ambassadeurs
c'est une nouveauté 2021 alors ses
ambassadeurs ils sont issus de grands
groupes et acteurs économiques déjà
implantés sur le territoire
quel va être son objectif alors
l'objectif de cette démarche ambassadeur
c'est vraiment de montrer comment nos
grands groupes nos grands industriels
ici à paris saclay peuvent porter haut
les couleurs de paris saclay dans leur
travail au quotidien
évidemment ce sont nos meilleurs porte
parole pour expliquer à travers leur
réunion au quotidien en france mais
aussi à l'international je dirais même
surtout à l'international
l'intérêt d'être au sein de cette
communauté d'une ovation qui est paris
saclay l'intérêt de s'implanter ici pour
travailler ensemble et améliorer l'état
de l'art de la recherche
donc ce sont tout simplement nos
meilleurs porte parole et donc on
voudrait leur passer le flambeau et donc
à l'occasion de cette édition 2021 on a
lancé cette démarche ambassadeurs et
trois grands groupes étaient avec nous
pour lancer cette démarche et d'autres
grands groupes du territoire vont je
l'espère nous rejoindre dernière
question jérémy hervé l'an prochain est
ce que vous préparez déjà la nouvelle
édition
oui on est déjà à pied d'oeuvre et on
aimerait beaucoup que cette prochaine
édition puisse se dérouler cette fois ci
dans les yvelines
donc on travaille pour le moment à
identifier où on pourra faire avoir lieu
cette prochaine édition qui je l'espère
pourra se dérouler cette fois en
présentiel et dans des conditions
sanitaires normal on l'espère tous merci
jérémy hervé d'avoir été avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes le directeur du
développement économique et de
l'innovation au sein de l'opéra paris
saclay m
et le reste de l'actualité de la semaine
c'est astrid bergère qui nous le résume
en 78 secondes
dix ans ont passé depuis la création de
l'association cynophiles de la police
municipale à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire l'association basé à
elancourt a remis un présent à la
commune qui a oeuvré pendant toutes ces
années à son développement
ils sont envahis vont se battre pour la
présidence de la région ile de france
les candidats et leurs listes pour les
élections régionales de juin prochain
ab jusqu'au 11 mai pour se déclarer
officiellement en préfecture
sans surprise valérie pécresse brigue un
nouveau mandat et selon les sondages son
principal opposant reste jardin bardella
pour le rassemblement national
c'est maintenant sur le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera la ligue des champions du
cyclisme sur piste le 20 novembre
la compétition qui aura lieu pour la
première fois sera réparti sur six
soirées et pendant six semaines
ils seront soixante douze à participer
19 mai cette date était attendue de tous
c'était la deuxième pas du déconfinement
les commerces non essentiels et les
lieux culturels ont pu rouvrir avec des
jauges réduite les bars et les
restaurants eux peuvent à nouveau
accueillir des clients en extérieur qui
dirait ouverture des lieux culturels dit
premier spectacle le 19 mai au soir la
batterie à guyancourt a organisé un
événement surprise une douzaine
d'artistes aux univers est-il différent
se sont succédé face à 80 spectateurs
[Musique]
et après cette semaine bien chargée et
quoi de mieux que de se détendre le week
end
comme chaque vendredi et même pendant
avec ceux des confinement célia gars
tsongo vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons aux aussi vous
aimez les animaux le zoo safari de
thoiry vient de rouvrir ses portes après
des mois de fermeture
plusieurs bébés sont nés durant le
confinement et sont donc à retrouver
dans le parc qui compte plus de 75
hectares en d'âge de xavier jallais au
parc de thoiry pendant le confinement
plusieurs bébés ont vu le jour comme les
makis cattas une espèce de lémurien un
couple de coyote est arrivé également le
27 avril
fermé depuis quasiment six mois le parc
de plus de 75 hectares a retrouvé ses
visiteurs en jouer moi j'ai vu des
kangourous perroquets les bébés
kangourous dans la poche des mamans
aussi des liens de mieux désinformées
crocodile est aussi une autruche
on en a profité c'est la réouverture et
puis avec les enfants le mercredi c'est
toujours il avait hâte de pouvoir
revenir
on a l'habitude de venir donc voilà on
avait hâte louis adore adore aller au
zoo où on a le pass annuel à thoiry donc
du coup du coup on y va et grand plaisir
oui depuis le 19 mai ces six oursons
seront aussi connaissance avec le public
ils sont nés cet hiver il passe deux
mois accroché à la main de sa maman dans
sa tanière
et il ressort dans le monde réel quand
il est capable de d'être être autonome
sur la partie froid et autres et
protection avec sa maman avec la crise
sanitaire le port du masque est toujours
obligatoire dans tout le parc et le zoo
au safari de thoiry a maintenu sa charte
so clean fays ça fait un an qu'on vit
avec un protocole sanitaire de 19 pages
où toute la restauration est en vente à
emporter sur les tables extérieures tout
à parti qu'elle s'est fait
majoritairement sur internet évidemment
on comprend aussi les gens qui viennent
sur place mais on met en vente les
billets en ligne un billet daté tour par
jour en fonction des jeux qu'on a et si
l'on veut poursuivre l'aventuré plus
longtemps qu'une journée le zoo de
thoiry propose une nuit dans l'une des
vingt asnières une nouveauté 2021 pour
dormir avec les ours les loups et les
bisons un salon arts et jardins dans le
domaine des dents
hier en yvelines première édition ce
week-end le 21 22 et 23 mai plus d'une
centaine d'exposants seront présents
pour vous faire découvrir leur savoir
faire en matière de jardinage et de
décoration pour l'occasion un jardin
éphémère de plus de 300 mètres carrés
sera réalisé et des concerts seront
prévues chaque soir tour du programme
dans l'interview express avec sandrine
angibaud l'organisatrice regarder il n'y
a pas de grand salon qui réunit tous les
professionnels de proximité donc l'aider
c'est quand même rencontré que le grand
public
des pépiniéristes d entreprise de
décoration de jardin et bien évidemment
des artisans menuisiers aussi spécialisé
dans les salons de jardin des vérandas
les paysagistes
voilà donc on a pas mal de artisans sur
le thème du jardin on à l'arc et au même
niveau que l'activité de jardin donc là
on a une cinquantaine d'artistes aussi
donc sculpteurs peintres
alors je crois qu'on va avoir évidemment
les amateurs jardin sa future je pense
qu'il va y avoir aussi des
professionnels qui vont venir
eh ouï dire et puis il ya les promeneurs
évidemment et puis il ya ceux qui aiment
l'art ceux qui sont attirés par l'art
vont avoir envie de visiter ce salon
je pense que là on va tirer quand même
plusieurs univers la fête de la nature
revient pour une quinzième édition le
département des yvelines l'organisent au
parc du peuple de l'herbe à carrières
sous poissy de 14h à 18h pour célébrer
la biodiversité
véronique brondeau bonsoir ça vous êtes
la directrice du parc du peuple de
l'herbe
cette année le thème de l'édition 2000
21 c'est à travers mille et un regard
pourquoi ce thème de l'observation qu'on
fait donc tout à chacun à n'a pas le
même regard sur la nature autographes on
ne la regarde pas de la même façon qu un
écologue ou encore à sportif et du coup
on a voulu donc va s'associer au thème
national et proposait donc une série
d'activités au grand public sur le thème
du regard
donc c'est pour ça qu'on retrouvera pas
mal d'activités dont on commet un
photographe donc qu'il présentera son
exposition à la maison des insectes
après midi et qui proposera aussi malin
donc un stage d'initiation donc à la
photographie on aura également beaucoup
de bain pas mal de balade
une balade nature ans insolite en
gyropode pour découvrir les différents
sites du parc une balade aussi pour les
pour les bébés de balade découverte des
papillons est aussi une balade sur les
petites bêtes pour les petites têtes
également donc des polonais proposé par
le comité de randonnée pédestre les
yvelines
donc cette année en fait on a on propose
pas mal d'activités pour les petits
puisque c'est une pré demande qui
ressortit des enquêtes qu'on a pu faire
sur le fond la populace pitt n'est
visité
le parc donc ça c'était pour les
activités dans le par et puis on a une
série d'ateliers autour de la maison des
insectes des ateliers lecture de paysage
on a aussi essayé d'aborder le thème à
travers le regard des animaux ceux des
oiseaux en fait ce qu'ils voient et
aussi des insectes
comment asseoir leur territoire leur
environnement donc c'était aussi ce ce
regard là pas uniquement de l'homme mais
aussi celui de la nature l'art il ya
beaucoup d'animations qui sont proposés
vous vous vous disiez mais qu'elles
seront un peu les temps forts durant cet
après-midi alors qu'on a un petit
spectacle s'appelle au fil des saisons
donc avec deux représentations à 15h30
et 16h30
donc on croise les doigts pour qu'ils
pas de pluie part parce que c'est tout
en plein air et puis et puis après bien
évidemment vous avez la maison des
insectes avec l'exposition d'insectes
vivants elle sera ouverte en accès libre
au public
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une deuxième
exposition aussi c'est l'exposition
temporaire regard sur les espaces
naturels sensibles dans les yvelines
de quoi va parler cette exposition en
fait c'est une exposition de sébastien
ogier c'est un photographe naturaliste
donc la photographier la faune et la
flore des villes en particulier sur les
espaces naturels sensibles donc le pas
du peuple de l'herbe est un espace
naturel sensible mais dans le bikini à
2800 hectares d'espacés naturels
sensibles est aussi l'occasion là de
mettre en avant les autres espaces
naturels sensibles des yvelines avec une
superbe photo donc je vous invite à
venir rencontrer le photographe
puisqu'il sera là dimanche samedi
après-midi pardon pour présenter au ces
clichés
durant cet après midi on on peut
fabriquer en famille une carte nature si
j'ai bien compris comment ça va se
passer
du coup en fait les
les participants auront à leur
disposition divers supports secret il
vous montre appliqué une carte nature
voilà d'accord il ya aussi donc vous
l'avez dit hein pas mal d'animations
pour les petits donc c est de un an à
partir d'un an jusqu'à cinq ans est-ce
que ce public est sensible à la
biodiversité à la nature oui c'est très
important en fait de pouvoir proposer
des activités dès le plus jeune âge
parce que tout ce qui est sa développe
les sens c'est très important pour les
pour leur développement personnel c'est
très enrichissant et le développement
par des activités d'éveil par les sens
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment c'est
très important et qu'on souhaitait le
proposait c'était une vraie demande
aussi du public et c'est ce sont des
animations à faire en famille j'imagine
oui effectivement voilà c'est ça ce sont
donc les parents à toute la famille est
invitée à accompagner l'oncle et les
enfants dans cette danse est découverte
de la flore du pare de toutes ces
richesses et toutes les animations sont
gratuites oui bien évidemment
elles sont gratuites après je ne cache
pas que avec les conditions sanitaires
donc le port du masque est obligatoire
dans le parc 1 mais avec les conditions
sanitaires y aura peut-être un peu un
petit que donc il faudra être patient
très bien grasset noté merci beaucoup
véronique brondeau d'avoir l'air d'être
invités merci m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page wazir je vous
propose des idées de sorties pour ce
week end la fête de la nature se déroule
aussi à plaisir de nombreuses animations
seront proposées samedi 22 mai à 10h30
une rando zéro déchet est organisée
départ à la maison des familles flora
tristan dimanche 23 mai vous pourrez un
troquer vos plants et graines au marché
de plaisir de 10h à 12h et l'émission
continue avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
oh
comme chaque semaine votre rendez-vous
en partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
on écoute vincent couronne docteur en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin et fondateur des cieux ligne
qu'est ce qui fait qu'une communauté
d'humains peut vivre en respectant des
règles communes
un des ingrédients de la recette social
c'est l'établissement de règles
supérieur qui plus est elles sont
nécessaires à la préservation de la
démocratie plus elles sont difficiles à
modifier
c'est à cette dure loi du vivre ensemble
que michel barnier devra se plier si et
s'y préparent il est élu président de la
république en 2022 car que propose-t-il
eh bien le suspendre une partie des
migrations et aussi de suspendre le
regroupement familial
outre que cette procédure ne concerne
qu'une infime part de l'immigration
légale cette promesse semble
juridiquement bien irréaliste et
politiquement impossible à tenir pour
quoi et bien parce que le regroupement
familial est un droit qui a d'abord été
prévu dans notre constitution dans une
disposition qui faudrait donc modifié et
donc réunir une majorité des trois
cinquièmes au parlement première
difficulté mais il voudrait aussi quitté
la cod à une convention européenne des
droits de l'homme qui protège elle aussi
ce droit au regroupement familial sauf
que quitter la cod h implique de quitter
aussi le conseil de l'europe une
organisation de 47 états qui veille à la
préservation de la démocratie
aucun parti sérieux en france pas même
les républicains ne propose un tel
séisme mais il faudrait encore réviser
une directive de l'union européenne
autrement dit avoir l'aval formel
notamment du parlement européen
clairement ce n'est pas demain la veille
qu'une majorité politique se dégagera en
europe sur cette promesse ou alors il
faudrait sortir de l'union européenne et
là encore le fch exit les mêmes plus au
programme du rassemblement national
c'est dire que la tâche serait
impossible tout ça il faut le dire pour
4% à peine de l'immigration légale soit
une dizaine de milliers de personnes
chaque année
mesdames et messieurs les républicains
êtes vous prêt à tirer au canon
pour écraser une mouche
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end du 22 au
30 mai la croix rouge française organise
ses journées nationales dans les
yvelines l'unité locale de sartrouville
et ses 70 bénévoles ont programmé des
journées de collecte sur trois communes
sartrouville maisons laffitte et le
mesnil le roi on écoute le président
pierre meyer au micro de michael et demi
d'euros nous y allons nous retrouver
avec un tronc de kate
évidemment à eau aux carrefours et on
profite de notamment deux de ces lieux
où les voitures peuvent s'arrêter où les
passants peuvent s'arrêter pour leur
proposer de participer à cette à cette
quête en mettant un peu d'argent il ya
un peu moins de liquidités quelque
précédemment mais dans dans les troncs
qu'on leur présente on va
essentiellement se concentrer sur ce
point de la couenne lohan mais également
éventuellement au carrefour de au
magasin carrefour de sartrouville et
font qu'on va récupérer en ce qui nous
concerne sartrouville
je rappelle quand même que chaque unité
locale de la croix-rouge est autonome
dans ses activités
essayant d'abord de répondre aux besoins
locaux et donc en ce qui nous concerne
on envisage de créer l'année prochaine
est passé à cette année parce que ça
demande un certain temps et c'est 90
notamment l'aménagement des locaux
qu'une prête la mairie de sartrouville
mais les créations d'un point d'hygiène
[Musique]
plus en plus de demandes dette
donc ça c'est le point dur et qu'on peut
imaginer liées à la situation
comprennent actuellement
et puis malgré tout on connaît un point
peut être positif qui est quand même qui
fait qu'ils rassurent c'est une
augmentation de la solidarité on reçoit
peut-être plus qu'avant on l'a reçu
pendant toute cette période des
propositions de bénévolat c'est la fin
de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi l'information
revient lundi à 18h en direct dans le
7-8 journal présenté par grégory canal
et d'ici là vos programmes se poursuivre
sur tv 78 et moi je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée et un très bon week
end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]